the question is what stands in most
people's way of achieving their dreams
it sounds simple we can achieve dreams
and you know there's a million books on
it but what do you think is actually the
block for many people I know I have
written a book called quit your day job
and lead the life of your dreams based
on my own experience and that of others
one of my favorite stories that was on
Joyce brothers television show years ago
with a couple of other people and one of
them was that a man in his it was then
in his 80s and just had received his law
degree from the University of Chicago
and he was Ito he told her that he was
standing in line for registration four
years earlier and one of the young
people and lying behind him said sir are
you sure you're in the right line and he
said and I turned around and I said what
line should I be in and I thought that
is America that's the essence of America
you you are in whatever line you want to
be in in this country and he fearlessly
walked up and stood in the line and got
his law degree at the age of 86 or
whatever he was and to me it what stands
in people's way is fear and and they're
their friends inflicted on them so one
of the chapters in my book has to do
with distinguishing between friends and
friendly associates because when I left
the academic world I had a few friends
and I had lots of friendly associates I
learned the difference when I decided to
leave because I retained a few friends
but most everybody I did not retain as
friends because they thought I was
absolutely crazy
they either thought that up in a kind of
benign way or they just thought I was I
mean they were they just were extremely
angry that I was leaving a tenured
position they thought that was
completely uncool and crazy and I could
also say that they were fearful about it
and I knew well I knew them well enough
to know that many of them were envious
wish they could do it but just wouldn't
do it because they're set in their ways
and that's one of the reasons I didn't
lie
tenure because it once you had tenure
you didn't have to publish anymore you
didn't have to do anything anymore
and of course if you're truly motivated
that's not going to stop you and there
were a few people who were unstoppable
but mostly they weren't unstoppable and
they just stopped and to me that was a
crime because I didn't understand
anything other than the merit system as
you know something that should rule an
academy of ideas you know so I think
what makes people afraid of being out on
the street you know it's an image that
that I've had you know in the first ten
years of getting into a new world where
I realized I wasn't gonna get a check
every two weeks regularly you know you
you have that image if you were raised
by depression your parents and and you
also have the other image of the wolves
at the door
I remember that one because I found a
quick way around it go to the door open
the door and if you don't see any wolves
at the door then there are no wolves at
the door but it is it is an image that
pops into your mind in the middle of the
night as as does the homeless image and
many other things but if you're afraid
of images then you shouldn't be in the
world of images I mean that's what I do
is I create images and develop images
and turn them into movies so how can I
let you know images that are in my brain
control my actions you have to learn to
overcome that and so I think people have
to clearly understand themselves and and
decide on who to listen to you know if
you truly are a friend and you love
somebody you encourage them to fulfill
their dreams and I always do that to my
students always felt like you have a
dream and you're afraid of accomplishing
it what if your dream is the most
important dream that ever came along in
the human race and you don't do anything
about it it was your dream and you do
nothing about it to me that's a
sacrilege you know you you had the dream
for a reason you know it's in your mind
for a reason either God put it there or
it was born in your mind from some other
source why aren't you going
do something about it well because I'm
afraid that my father mother would be
really upset that goes so this is a
hypothetical fear about something that
hasn't happened yet right yes
then why not just do it and deal with
the possibility that may never happen at
all and that's it's a matter of knowing
yourself I mean that's one of the things
I talk about first in the book I was
raised on Greek philosophy and when it
said over the Oracle of Delphi was know
thyself that's was the most important
piece of knowledge that Plato and
Aristotle and Socrates taught and
knowing yourself means you know you're
gonna be haunted by this dream if you
don't do it I mean I've had a partner
who said once when her movie was in
trouble maybe this is one of those
dreams that should never have happened
and I know that is complete blasphemy
you know you say that now but later you
will see that that was that when there
was some other voice talking to you
other than your own voice because you
you made this thing happened and you
know you will be proud of it as she was
and that's I think the simply fear is
the number one impediment to people
going for their dreams and it's fear you
know everyone knows that acronym is
about fear it's fear is about things
that haven't happened yet that may never
happen just like worry and we all do it
we all have fears we all have worries
but overcoming your fears is what you
know valiant people do it's what you
know people that you would like to be
like do so why not do it yourself and
and not have to live with the regret
which is a big monster equal to fear
that you live with if you are sitting on
that proverbial front porch in your
rocking chair thinking about the dreams
that you had and didn't do way to me
that's a terrible waste of life to have
that happen also stripping away
illusions and you talk about knowing
thyself and being comfortable enough to
know that if you have
stand by yourself for a while because
you've lost the illusion of some of the
friendships or peer group that you
thought was going to be there with you
if for whatever reason socially they've
gone the other way knowing that that's
okay as well yeah I mean that's a very
good point because I think as you get
older you realize that you cannot govern
your life by what other people think and
it's you know I live on the 11th floor
and I look out over the millions of
lights and in Los Angeles and it's a
great comfort to think that there are
you know a few lights out there that
love me you know there are maybe fewer
that hate me and but there are millions
that have no idea that I exist that's
comfortable and it's sort of the cosmic
view of life when you think about it
you're you're just one little tiny piece
of a massive cosmos that is going about
its massive mechanism with on its own
without any need for you to consult with
it and for you to be worried about what
you know some other person somewhere
else thinks about you it's a complete
waste of your energy in every way your
job is to do what your dreams tell you
to do and to do it with all your might
the way the cosmos does and what other
people are saying and thinking and doing
first of all because most of them are
not spending any time thinking about you
at all could care less what you do or
don't do most of them are think you know
me about themselves so that's a natural
condition and why should you be any
different you know if you have a dream
just do it and you fear that the crazy
painter that it's been turning out
paintings in the garage down the street
and everyone thinks you're cracked
laughs but then they learned that you
sold one of your paintings for a million
dollars and now it's gonna be in the
Louvre you know suddenly they go I
always knew that that gal was a genius
you know she she really had talent from
the very beginning people change
instantly which shows how much value of
their opinion really has right and
that's why I just think it's you know
you've got to really listen to yourself
and and not listen to everybody else
a few people you can tell your friends
because the ones that supports you in
doing that are your true friends mmmn
yeah if the person who's not supporting
you is I've had several clients in my
career who whose spouses did not support
them and you know my advice is divorce
your spouse I'm sorry you know like I
take this seriously I do this is a
profession this is a vocation and if you
know someone close to you is telling you
don't do it it's selfish you need to get
somebody else close to you you know who
will encourage you because I'll let all
the monumental great things in life I
think are done by people who go for it
and who are not afraid of taking a
chance and who are there for it
supported by a few true friends you know
or loved ones who tell them to do it you
know it's many examples from my own life
but when I decided to leave the tenured
position my daughter was a junior at
Columbia and one thing that would be
jeopardized would be her senior year at
Columbia and I brought her up to
Montreal where I was shooting movies and
we had a long talk about it you know off
set and she said Dan you absolutely have
to do this you have to do it don't worry
about that and of course that problem
got solved and didn't have being a
problem but it was a concern but she had
no concern for it and that's how I know
now who my true friends are and that's
how her you would know - if you decide
you want to do something listen
carefully to what the people around you
say because when people are telling you
know they're expressing their own fears
and some of it may be good hearted
they're afraid that the things they fear
may happen to you but if you're willing
to take the risk you know don't let them
influence you because they're not taking
the risk
you know I'm unless they depend on you
and then you have to figure that out and
I and I did certain things when I left
that career to make sure that those who
depended on me would not you know end up
being left without resources so I did
what I had
to do to make sure that happened and
then once I did that I mic my conscience
was clear and I was able to embrace it
fully with all the risks that it
entailed and I you know no regrets even
though there are some very dark times
and and there always ups and downs in a
business like this one and you know
career that is bereft of security you
know the other side of that coin is that
as much as security as an illusion
rejection is also an illusion because
you can take as many chances as you want
you know I constantly hear people tell
me even on the phone this morning you
only get one shot that was the
distributor telling me we only get one
shot and I thought well ok maybe that's
true for you but I get as many shots as
I want to take and Hollywood is you know
personal doesn't exist
what is Hollywood right it's just a
concept but in reality the business that
I'm in all you have to do is tell
somebody I've got a great news story and
they are all ears immediately they don't
care that it's been ten years since you
talked to them you know you spend a few
seconds in chit chat and then they want
to hear the story so you can take as
many you know as many chances as you
want to take unless your own psychology
disallows that because it wants you to
get depressed and you know spend go into
a coma of unhappiness and take rejection
seriously etc I just don't have time you
know one of my essays is called the
waiting room and it's about what you do
while you're waiting for an answer on a
creative project well you don't wait you
do something else you know you make
another creative project you get it
going and by the you know if you keep
doing that every project has its own
clock you can't do much to control that
clock but you can be doing another
project and sooner or later you have
projects all around you that are in
various states of a ripeness and they
will happen in their own time and your
biggest problem will be what if two of
them happened at the
same time and I always say don't worry
about that I mean that's the kind of
problem you want to have you don't want
to have the problem of nothing happening
so no you don't wait at all and I think
a lot of writers torture themselves
because they wait you know they send off
a manuscript hypothetically into the
snail mail no one does that anymore but
they send it off and then they wait for
an answer why would they wait for an
answer that's complete waste of time
instead you instantly work on something
else and that way when something comes
from the first thing you're just
surprised and you're you deal with it
meet it immediately without wasting any
kind of psychological energy on it you
just if it's a rejection you take take
it and you move on and if it's a if it's
somebody offering you a deal then you
consider the deal but you don't writers
feel like they have to spend an
additional 90 percent of their time
fretting over at all analyzing it you
know soul-searching over it and you do
that when you're younger and it's fine
to do summer because you may get a lot
of creativity out of it but once you've
gone through it and tortured yourself
you know to your own satisfaction you
don't have to do that all the time you
can just go back to work and Ray
Bradbury used to say that to writers get
back to work it'll get rid of all these
moods you're having you know and I
always thought that's the most brilliant
advice work is the solution
you